le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
pour la sixième année consécutive le
jardin de l'état se réinvente boucle
d'or blanche-neige grand mère kal
s'invite pour cette nouvelle édition de
bonheur des enfants
avec pour thème cette année les comptes
petits et grands peuvent venir profiter
pendant huit jours d'animations
d'attraction et d'ateliers dans un décor
onirique préparé par les agents du
département
[Musique]
il
derniers ajustements pour l'équipe de la
cellule défi alors on est ici dans
l'atelier textile
donc nous on s'occupe un petit peu de
tout ce qui est mobilier d'intérieur
dans quelques jours débutera la sixième
édition de bonheur des enfants artistes
et artisans du département s'activent
pour que tout soit prêt dans les temps
et du côté des capitaux nerfs on fait du
neuf avec du vieux
des fauteuils qu'on a récupéré dans dans
un dépôt au département et au lieu de
les laisser mourir au département et non
laisser se faire manger par les petites
bêtes je les ai récupérées et puis
bientôt on va essayer de
ausculté les pieds pour ceux qui sont
cassés éventuellement certains sont en
cours et puis voilà il ya encore un
petit peu de travail à deux pas de
l'atelier on valorise le bois de
goyavier tout en partageant des
connaissances leur mission il est à deux
vitesses
la première fait transmettre du savoir
faire sur des publics bénéficiaires de
contrats aidés
nos jeunes là quand ils arrivent ici ne
connaissent pas particulièrement parce
que c'est pas des ébénistes des mini dié
donc il arrive il
il découvre la première fois qu'ils font
ils découvrent ils s'approprient les
utiles ou les en art on a un espace
d'exposition et de démonstration de te
prends peut faire une fois terminées les
quelques 100 ouvrages en bois de
goyavier fabriqués par la filière sont
acheminés vers le jardin de l'état
[Musique]
ici des dizaines d'agents sont déjà à
l'oeuvre pour installer les plus grosses
structures sous l'oeil bienveillant de
tatiana pas de chama j'ai choisi comme
axe les maisons de compte
parce que je voulais que quelque part
les des cinq comptes puissent prendre
forme en fête dans le jardin pour que le
public puisse devenir les acteurs du
livre en face des histoires l'idée c'est
que l'extérieur et dans des matériaux
comme le textile le bois dont tous les
toits des maisons sans c1 textile mais
l'intérieur des maisons sont le mobilier
est en carton
donc l'idée c'était d'amener les gens
quand ils rentrent dans la maison d'être
dans le livre en fête et puis devient le
petit chaperon rouge deviennent boucle
d'or et de vienne
les sept nains ou blanche-neige aaa
comme ils souhaitent pas ou le grand
méchant loup
[Musique]
pour sa troisième collaboration avec le
département la scénographe à miser sur
l'interactivité et la transmission
la scénographie c'est toute la partie en
amont en fait on réfléchira décor et
ensuite il ya l'événement est
l'événement c'est quand on transmet au
public ce qu'on a imaginé pour que se
l'approprient et lui donne vie en fait
et quand j'en vois les enfants dedans
c'est juste c'est juste merveilleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bonheur des enfants est devenu un
rendez vous attendu des familles
réunionnaises
la diversité des activités proposées par
le jardin attire chaque année un public
plus nombreux
vous piloterez le véhicule vous aurez en
main le volant nous on rat et on
aura juste 9 points on vous fera
confiance
bien entendu
[Musique]
je trouve que quand je disais vraiment
le bonheur des enfants parce qu'ils sont
les sons voulait voir vraiment épanoui
sont très heureuses
il en redemande et
je pense que même là il faudrait que les
familles reviennent avec eux parce que
la journée qu'on passe les passions
qu'ils ont tellement il ya à faire mais
j'ai trouvé le stand des rapaces très
intéressant à voir vraiment parce que et
les dvd soit son bol et le
la personne qui s'en occupe et explique
très bien les enfants même pu caresser
courant au bout c'est vraiment très
proche de la nature
ferme pédagogique patinoire manège même
les principaux intéressés ne savent plus
où donner de la tête
et aussi on a fait aussi mes voitures le
car on a fait le carton est des voitures
heure là on a fait trois fois
ah ouais on est rentré dans la maison de
la safer suivi un bonnet de sorcières
avec une citrouille vient et depuis six
ans cet événement gratuit au coeur de la
ville permet d'apporter l'esprit de noël
à toutes les familles réunionnaises
l'amour c'est quelque chose de gratuit
et le bonheur c'est aussi quelque chose
de gratuit ce pour ça que nous avons
voulu faire de cette opération une
opération gratuite ouvert au plus grand
nombre de réunionnais parce que en fin
d'année on a envie d'ouvrir son coeur on
a envie de partager de belles choses de
faire rayonner des étoiles dans la tête
de tout le monde pas seulement des
tout-petits et je crois qu'on ne réussit
bien parce que c'est une opération qui
est aujourd'hui plébiscité par
l'ensemble des réunions
[Musique]
cette année le jardin de l'état s'est
vêtu des couleurs des comptes européens
et réunionnais ouvert du 16 au 23
décembre
le département propose structures
gonflables manèges les ateliers
culturels et des spectacles multimédias
c'est un événement gratuit pour tous les
publics
fruit de plusieurs mois de travail
l'événement est également une vitrine du
savoir-faire de près de 80 agents du
département
sur l'ensemble du jardin 90 stands ont
été montés et plus de 60% des anciennes
décorations ont été recyclés sur les
huit jours d'ouverture au bonheur des
enfants accueille pas moins de 80 mille
personnes pour plus d'informations
rendez vous sur le site du département
ou www.cglpl.fr
[Musique]